i will like to invite our first speaker
dr jeet sarkar
who is again
a passionate uh speak
passionate researcher who is mining and
doing biomedical data analysis for
better clinical outcome and has been
contributing by applying knowledge by
doing translational uh research and
finding solutions and multi omics
analysis as well as uh learning and
applying it for clinical informatics so
over to you um
dr jeet sakkar
thanks mohit
so am i audible
yes yes
so i'll just share my screen
so is my screen visible
yes
okay so
thanks uh thanks morgan for the
opportunity to uh
talk on this topic uh so uh as far as we
all know clinical informatics is still
in a very immature stage and considering
the
deficiency of
proper curated structured clinical data
and considering the
impact of this particular field it's
still in a developing scenario
so i will just cover some of the use
cases and some of the models which
which we we have been developing and
which which i have been developing to
address various clinical problems and i
also brief
in these three particular sections so
first i will talk about the solution
categories so what are the possible
categories in which
the clinical use cases can be
bucketed followed by a solution life
cycle because clinical data is rapidly
generated and
so the clinical models need to be
rapidly updated and so on and lastly i
will just give a walk through uh of the
use cases of a few use cases uh from
clinical informatics
so uh starting with uh my background so
i i have done my mbbs almost six years
back so by training i am a clinician
followed by
my
expertise in
data science and
mostly building models for metabolic
diseases so that's how i wanted to
combine these two area to
develop these
variables
so
to summarize we can have
so we we have been working i have been
working on
six different type of solutions
so starting with the uh left one
so this is the broad category of
predictive analytics so this is more of
a uh supervised modeling where there are
use cases like days to get hospitalized
length of state prediction it's a very
important marker for
for
the hospital performance
chronic disease risk prediction and of
course mobility prediction so these are
all predictive models where we have the
data and we can improve some predictions
next concept cluster identification
we can identify disease subtypes we can
identify sub-specialists so today
things are going to a
sub-specialization model that
we go for
retina specialist we go for strabismus
specialist so this is this is the domain
of the ophthalmologists so how we can
identify these sub specialist doctors
within our domain of ophthalmologists
these clusters can also be identified
from clinical data
we can also identify disease clusters
whether what are the diseases which
which tend to co-occur in a certain
population group of of a population of a
certain age
and we can also identify equation
clusters
next we compute time series analysis now
time series is a very important uh part
uh given the advantage of these
variables and fitbits so it's massive
amount of data generated each and every
second and so because the vital
parameters of
human
of human
body are rapidly fluctuating so we can
predict the
blood pressure or respiratory date or
uh so using some time series models so
uh
from the perspective of uh
hospitals and uh healthcare providers
you can also predict footfall prediction
so because you know there are certain
diseases which are acute and seasonal so
there is the uh there is a trend and
seasonal uh seasonal nature of patient
coming to the opd's and clinics so in
order to
properly manage the
uh manage the burden of patients and the
doctors so we can also do footfall
prediction and lastly vitals prediction
in icu which is a major because in the
in the intensive care unit there are
lots of parameters constantly measured
almost every minute or even every hour
so those prediction also comes under the
peripheral cancer analysis
next we come to image analysis so it's
very it's a very much emerging field
with last decade where
x-rays and city science and mris and
even even usg these all things can be
automated to a certain certain extent
uh also for the pathological images with
tissue sections this can also be
automated to certain extent
another
important part is the handwritten text
analysis this is very important for
healthcare domain
because healthcare still has massive
amount of data
in uh hard hard copy format so digital
formats you don't always get in
countries like in asian countries and in
multiple countries where there has been
not the healthcare system hasn't yet
been almost
digitized there are plenty of
handwritten texts and scanned pdfs and
all those things and converting them to
digital data and structuring them
cleaning them
then extracting medical entities to get
insights
this is a very big domain in
clinical informatics
and
anything can be a combination of all
these
all these five categories and it will be
a customized model and that model can
also be developed so so clinical
informatics covers this broad range of
offerings of healthcare solutions
so how does a solution lifecycle look
like in digital information so suppose
i work with clients
where customers can come with some
their data or their requirements so
there will be some introduction
and meeting for the use cases
and
followed
followed by that there will be some
identification of possible model
solutions for the use cases
then we'll uh come the data
exploratory data analysis which is just
to explore the data how it looks to
provide some uh basic data in sites and
then to uh propose the models now this
portion is the most vital vital part
from data idiot with the best model uh
proposal and this and here there is a
constant iterative process to uh look
for more suitable models which can best
solve the clinical question and lastly
and and perhaps the most important part
is the
deployment and integration of these
models to the clinical workflow because
the clinical workflow is already super
burdened uh be be anywhere in the world
so integration of a new technology of a
new model
to the existing clinical clinical
workflow assigning nurses or physicians
to use that clinical model for their
clinical
predictive purpose or assigning a new
person who will do this job on on
on their part this is a very uh
important part and that's where it also
ensures a
repeated iterative process where this
usability is again and again tested
unless the uh model is properly fit
within the clinical workflow
so now
the use cases so just
overview now i will discuss
today about i just give some examples of
supervised models unsupervised models
graph network models and some time
series models so we can just
build some business insights you can
optimize the cost of expenses of the
hospital
uh
uh an evolving concept is value-based
care
value-based care care means where
there is
every clinical treatment or a clinical
intervention
is
can be quantified as something valuable
so
the healthcare system is gradually
shifting towards value-based care the
insurance companies in the us and
other countries they are also focusing
on value-based care so
so models can also be used for this risk
stratification and then i identifying
high-risk patients uh
catering uh with them more frequently uh
so so that the
care is more of uh value and that serves
the purpose of the insurance companies
also clinical insights data labeling
model model validation risk
stratification
so this these are some use cases now an
important part is feature engineering
because in clinical domain you have lots
of features and lots of different types
of features so it's a very uh
very
mixed type of data set so engineering
those those features to get uh
proper features which can be fed to the
model
uh and which
and which will be having a high
predictive value uh
identifying those things and feature
engineering is a very important part of
clinical informatics
a model selection translational insights
is very important
and so predictive models clustering
models ocr where we can just
scan and extract handwritten nodes image
analysis
some use cases that are here and then
finally the application development iot
management wearable integration and
remote monitoring these are also some
some possible use cases
so now
doing a div time so i will just uh walk
through the
skeleton of a supervised model workflow
just to give an idea of how
the thing can be designed so on the left
you can see the data sources so we are
having
electronic health records we can have
wireless variables medical devices
clinical notes pharmacy records then
regular service lab investigations now
these data types are of various
different structures so we we
first of all you have to structure it
and we have to uh make it
machine readable so these all deposited
to the to the database so we you also
have to connect
these all these things via suitable
hardware so that this data is
is ingested and properly curated on on
real time then comes the date of data
preparation and from there you can get
certain variables you can get social
demographic variables you can get
comorbid
conditions lifestyle habits self-taken
surveys real-time
fighters now each category will be
having multiple
features and those will be fed to the
training data set will be a validation
to develop the model and now this model
can be used to predict as i already told
length of state prediction chronic
disease risk prediction hospital
re-admission prediction
so predicting post of complications
vital parameter prediction and all those
things and the model can be customized
and updated as
the clinical needs and other things and
we can also do some sort of feature
important scoring where we can identify
that these three features or these four
features are the most important for
predicting length of state so maybe
these three features should be the
more frequently
monitored features uh for this
particular set of patients so this sort
of model can help us
help us
predict these sort of clinical outcomes
so
for the unsupervised model workflow i i
just presented one use case so
suppose uh
we had data of ophthalmologists
and they have been treating particular
diseases now all the diseases have some
standard icd groups so if a
ophthalmologist treats and suppose i see
uh suppose uh our disease scored like
six and g one three eight so
number of cases of g1 g8 he or she has
treated
is in a tabular format now these and
all suppose this all these
ophthalmologists will be clustered uh in
an unsupervised manner
and after clustering when we when we
when we saw the visualization
what we found is so that was uh certain
so this
so that there was a difference in the
clusters suppose this blue dots these
were mainly those ophthalmologists who
were catering ocular muscles and eye
movement reflex reflection diseases
this green cluster were those who are
providing
multi colloid and retinal diseases
and we found that these green
green physicians were mainly
regenerative specialists and these blue
ones were mainly pediatric ophthalmology
and establishment specialist so so you
can already identify these sub
specialists who are particularly expert
expert in a sub domain of a particular
ophthalmological domain
now this can be of multiple help
so maybe
in this case
so because if so all of you i guess
understand a pca so a pcm means these
blue and these
red
axis they are more or less at a 90
degree so
blue people
don't contribute to the
green one so that means
specialists are
don't uh cater a service for pediatric
ophthalmology and strabismus and the uh
also the other way around so if i can
identify a specialist who is having both
these skills then that is a very common
very rare combination and those those
persons
can be a sort of a common door
to these
sub specialists so these sorts of
business insights and healthcare
insights can also be
extracted from this provides
unsupervised model workforce
so next i was talking about the graph
name network
models so suppose in a population we
know that
people generally in the geriatric
population they suffer from multiple
diseases
so the person has diabetes as well as
high potential as well as dyslipidemia
or hyperthyroid and other use cases so
if we could identify
that at which age group
and given a gender
what are the
most common co-occurring diseases
for that particular group
if we could find that then given a new
person comes we can just
provide a much more personalized
screening program that so you fall in
the category of 60 and you are a male
so and you are having diabetes so in
that case you may be having hypothyroid
and
hypertension and eye disease
so you should be screened for these
three or four diseases
so uh to achieve this what we did we
took uh the disease conditions of all
patients and we
so
and we calculate the frequencies so the
nodes are the frequencies and if
the two nodes are connected that means
these two diseases
uh tend to occur more frequently in the
population so suppose one percent is
diagnosed with uh long-term current use
of aspirin in that case there is a good
probability of that person suffering
from hyperepidemia suffering from
insomnia suffering from uh primary
osteoarthritis suffering from vitamin d
deficiency so this person should be
screened for this uh this surrounding
five diseases suppose another person
comes with another particular disease so
for that that the set of nodes will be
different so this will help us to cater
a much more precise and personalized uh
straining health cleaning workflow from
person to person
so in this case we just uh designed it
so just to showcase this thing so these
six these seven diseases are having are
closed related to the long term uh use
of aspirin so any person coming with
this uh diagnosis should also be street
for other these five conditions so there
are already some training protocols in
place where one person having over 40
should be diagnosed should be strained
for this condition but this will make
things much more precise and
personalized
lastly the time series model which is uh
perhaps the most important uh or because
it's a very huge data so here you can
see this is the respiratory rate of one
person uh
fluctuating with time so every two
seconds ah the reading has been taken
now you can see in this particular
condition there is a huge
increase of the respiratory rate
compared to the other
findings so here there must be must have
some abnormality or some
exercise outburst or anything
so if we could predict these
uh this hyper
value
from the preceding values then we could
have prevented or alerted the patient
that you might be having an increased
respiratory rate in the coming uh
two or three minutes so be cautious so
these sorts of things are also
are also right now a bit are also right
now a bit more
hypothetical and these are being
tried by people to model but this is how
the use case looks like so here we can
apply something called change point
algorithm so what it what what it does
is it takes the entire stretch and
breaks the stretch into certain
certain slices
and
for this slice the mean standard
deviation
is
different from this slice having a
different mean and
minus standard deviation so we can so we
can identify these abnormal slice what
the mean and sd is
significantly different from the
preceding as well as the succeeding uh
areas and in this case there's one
problem is data has to be real time uh
synchronized and analyzed so uh that is
a different problem it's more of an
engineering problem and in that case we
can also set parameters and rules that
if the value is over this certain thing
then give a alert
and we can also build data driven
insights that if the data tells that the
person is going to have an increased
respiratory rate or heartbeat then
please alert the patient and the
surrounding
physician doctor ambulance and all those
things
so uh just lastly coming to the end of
my talk i will just briefly give uh
overview of how end-to-end workflow for
chronic disease may look like so we can
just
get the data the data acquisition from
the wearables and medical devices we can
do the data prep feature engineering
model building clinical decisions
support which will be validated with the
physicians and lastly we can use that
thing to produce automated alerts uh so
as to
help predict abnormal events
help recognize skipped medicine doses so
if somebody is having a abnormally
increasing blood pressure then we should
check that whether the person has
skipped his or his
medicine for the last one week or what
is the compliance and that can also be
put in as an alert to the person and to
the concerned caregiver
for mental health it's a very
important
topic coming up and
predicting
suicides predicting depression
attacks and panic attacks uh manic phase
prediction in
bipolar disorder and for this that the
data source is much more
much more comprehensive clinical data
genomic data vocal expression data
because the vocal expression how the
person is talking about the phone that
changes
and the facial expression changes social
media and regular survey all these
things can be uh structured and
fit into the model and accordingly we
can do prediction it's it's definitely
very
critical and there are certain ethical
issues and lots of legal issues but this
is the uh
this is the one direction in which
mental health is also going to proceed
towards so i just end my talk here and
i'll just take any questions for the
last
five or seven minutes thank you
thank you so much uh dr jeet for this
wonderful wonderful talk where we
learned about a lot of uh
application or driven uh
how can you how the industry is looking
at the problems and
finding solutions for what what the
students have learned i guess is also
the same and i i think that we have some
questions
so stanika are there any questions from
this from the
participants
or shri kari
i think some asana guys
putting it in the chat
so let me read it out for you um dr
sirkar so what are the possible career
options for people pursuing
bioinformatics in
bioinformatics and clinical informatics
so
so uh biometrics mainly consists of uh
till now uh genomics transcriptomics uh
proteomics metabolomics and uh
maybe metagenomics so uh
a lot of these
these omics approaches and the data
generated from them
uh this is going to be used for uh
coupled with clinical trial data
and with clinical prediction so the
thing is not
so mature right now because as i told
there is a certain
lack of bridge between health care
providers and bioinformatics but this is
whether
so there are companies who are trying to
and trying to integrate omics data with
clinical trial and clinical uh
clinical
outcome data and those are really big
big short things which are coming up so
if somebody can have the skill set of
bioinformatics and is having the
orientation to apply that in clinical
care and clinical trial data
that would be a great uh great career in
the coming days
almost a year still i i i hope that
all right and that's that's i think that
is helpful uh
next there is a question by dr chitra
mal uh he's asking that graph theory can
identify the group of closely related
diseases uh can we predict which will
come earlier
okay so uh so i guess
graph theory uh so in graph networks
there are also temporal graph networks
so
if we can build temporal graph networks
in that case we can do predict but i
will tell one thing
the major problem is with data so
so suppose a person is having four
diseases so hypertension diabetes
and hypothyroid and dyslexia so what is
the particular chronology of this
disease is something very tough to
disciple the person had gone for
a clinical visit got tested with
diabetes and then also found that he is
suffering from hypertension but whether
hypertension came before or diabetes
that is a very difficult thing to
comment for a real world patient but
this should be something which should
also be right and given we can have
longitudinal data uh from a certain age
where disease doesn't set in and we are
having
annual checkups then we can have those
data and temporal graph networks can
really identify this sequence of
diseases
yes all right
thank you thank you so much for that
answer one last question uh rissy m west
longa she's asking uh thank you doc for
a great presentation uh could you shed
some light on your work with metabolic
disorders
okay so uh my work was mainly on type 2
diabetes so now as you know type 2
diabetes is known to be a obesity driven
disease that people who are obese tend
to have
diabetes more but
as you may know that there is a there
are certain studies coming up which tell
that type diabetes can also occur in
so-called non-obvious persons now
those non-obvious persons may have some
increased visceral fat lower muscle mass
that's a different discussion but why
why do these non-obese type 2 persons
also become diabetic because these
persons
they contribute to over 50 percent of
the indian population so in india over
50 percent of type 2 diabetes patients
are having a low body mass index body
muscle index less than 25 so my study
was mainly to explore the underlying
pathophysiology and i covered that so i
studied the
adipose tissue of non-obese and obese
diabetic persons uh
biologically and uh cells using using
cell biology and i studied
terminological data sets and also
clinical reports so that there are
multiple
multiple
levels of the entire thesis and you can
find it on research gate or just by
searching me on google scholar citation
and you can just
have a good understanding